[موسيقى
] عشت دائمًا
في مدن كبيرة ، لذلك عشت في باريس
طوال حياتي ، فأنا رجل مدينة ومثل
المدن الكبرى
ألهمني ، ولذا فأنا أعيش في
نيويورك الآن
ولكني دائمًا في مدينة كبيرة  إن
طاقة المدينة الكبيرة هي ما
ألهمني لركوب دراجتي ، كما تعلمون فقط لا
أعرف السيارات التي تدور
حول الأشخاص الذين يتحدثون معي فقط عندما أركب
والطاقة الكاملة التي أعتقد أنني
جميل مثل الشخص المكثف ،
اخترت الأرض المسطحة على الفور
أولاً وقبل كل شيء لأنه في مدينتي لم
تكن هناك حديقة تزلج على
الإطلاق ، لذلك كنا فقط نركب
في الشارع كما تعلم أنه كان
مسطحًا جدًا ، لذلك مع صديقي
كنا نركلها في ساحة انتظار السيارات
لقد تعلمت فقط بعض الحيل المسطحة
عندما بدأت في التحسن فيها ،
اكتشفت أن الأرض المسطحة هي واحدة
من الانضباط الوحيد في العالم
حيث لا يزال بإمكانك ابتكار
الحيل على أساس شهري
لم يفعله أحد من قبل والآن
هذا هو  ما
يثير اهتمامي في ما أفعله هو أنني أريد
أن تكون حياتي اليومية مختلفة كل يوم
لا  روتيني
[موسيقى]
التقاط صورة جيدة لـ bmx هو
بالتأكيد تعاون
بين الفارس والصورة لدي
رأي قوي جدًا فيما أعتقد أنه
يبدو رائعًا ونعم ، لذا فأنا
أقول نوعًا ما الحيل التي
أعتقد أنها ستبدو مريضة و
يختار المصور الزاوية عندما
نجعلها تلتصق ببعضها البعض ، فأنت تعلم أن الأمر
يشبه نوعًا من العمل الجماعي مثل عمل الأحلام
الذي يقولون أنك تعرفه
[موسيقى
] انتهى بنا المطاف في سويتو التي تعد واحدة
من أكبر البلدات في جنوب إفريقيا حيث
كنا مع صديق إسباني فيكي جوميز
من هو
أبيض أيضًا ، وهو في الأساس بلدة سوداء
، لذلك عندما وصلنا لأول مرة
إلى هناك ، كان الكثير من الناس مثل
أوه ، لماذا أنت هنا ، فأنت
لا تريد التقاط صور لنا أو
أيًا كانت ليست حديقة حيوانات ملعون  هنا
لأنه يحدث الكثير من
الأشخاص البيض يذهبون إلى هناك ليحبوا
تصوير الفقر ، أنا
مثلك تعلم لكننا بدأنا في
الركوب وتغيرت نظرتهم إلينا
وبدأوا في أن يأتوا من
كل مكان وأنشأوا هذه
الدائرة الضخمة و  أحد الأطفال
من البلدة كان لديه أكبر عدد من الأحياء
اليهودية على الإطلاق
وكان يقوم ببعض الحيل على حيل الأرض المسطحة
وأتذكر أنني
رأيت أنني كنت مثل يا إلهي هذا
مذهل وفي اليوم الأخير
سألت الرجل الذي نظم  رحلة
للتواصل مع هذا الطفل
واطلب منه القدوم إلى المطار
لمقابلتنا ، وفي المطار أعطيته
دراجتي ، وما زال يركب دراجتي اليوم بعد
10 سنوات
[موسيقى]
أنا  سأكون خط النهاية الخاص بي ،
سأقرر متى أريد إنهاء الكاميرا الخاصة بي ،
كما تعلمون
عندما لا أكون متحمسًا أو لست جيدًا
بما يكفي للمنافسة الصحيحة ،
سأخبر راعي ، مرحباً يا رفاق ، شكرًا جزيلاً على
الرحلة